[موسيقى]
بعد مرور اسبوعين على الاشتباكات المسلحه
في السودان يبقى معبر ارجين احد اهم
المنافذ البريه التي لجا اليها السودانيون
للعبور الى الاراضي المصريه
[موسيقى]
مجرد ما قالوا الحرب في السولاف خلاص
اعصابنا يتوترت ليه لانه في النهايه
الاهلنا اولادنا اللي بنموت ما شفنا حلاوه
رمضان لانه الحرب كان يعني يوم العيد يوم
العيد في قتل
عشان كده احنا نفسيه ما مرتاحين
[موسيقى]
ومنذ بدايه الازمه والجميع في حاله انتظار
اصحاب سيارات الاجره واصحاب الحافلات
والاكثر تضررا اصحاب السيارات المخصصه
لنقل البضائع من خلال هذا المعبر احنا يا
دوبك دخلنا على مكان اللي هننزل فيه ما
فيش خمس دقايق وسمعنا الضرب ده يعني زي ما
يكون جهنم اتفتحت قال لك احنا هنوقف الشغل
ده لما نعدي الناس اللي جايين من المعبر
وبعدين هنعمل اعاده تصدير للعربيات اللي
في المحايد وبعد كده اللي بره ده هيرجع
[موسيقى]
هذه الرحلات الطويله سيبقى معبر وارجين
خالدا في اذهان الكثير من المصريين
والسودانيين والاجانب احمد عثمان لقنتي
العربيه والحدث من معبر ارجين على الحدود
المصريه السودانيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات